[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing boguts
and famed dark wizard captor alistair
madai moody
more specifically i'm going to be
addressing a question
that a lot of you have asked me which is
can
alistair madai moody see the true form
of a boggart
with his magical eye interesting facts
about pockets that i bet you didn't know
they exist in our own muggle world and
in the magical harry potter world
however while they share the same name
they are a little different
in our own muggle world boguts are
creatures from folklore
that come in two forms a household
spirit
or a malevolent creature that inhabits
places like fields
and marshes the household pocket does
harmless but
mischievous things like making things
disappear
the more sinister malevolent bogut that
resides in marshlands
is associated with darker behavior and
is known
for doing things like abducting children
these boguts also go by
many other names including but not
limited to
bug bears bogeymen and bogles in harry
potter on the other hand
boguts are essentially the manifestation
of our deepest darkest fears they are
immortal
shape-shifting non-beings that transform
themselves into whatever it is
that we fear most supposedly no one
knows what a pocket looks like
and that's because generally they
transform as soon as you encounter them
from the moment you lay your eyes on
them they have transformed into your
deepest
darkest fear when boguts aren't scaring
people
they can usually be found rustling
around in confined spaces or lurking
around
dark corners similar to poltergeists
which have an affinity for mischief
and dementors which thrive on darkness
and depression
boggarts are paired with fear another
frightening fact about boguts is that
when they transform into something
they adopt the properties of that thing
i.e
when a boggart transforms into a
dementor it's able to do
all of the horrible things that a
dementor can the boggart's power
however will be much less potent than
the original being
if you fear several things equally then
a bucket will manifest itself in the
form of each of your fears
cycling through them for maximum
emotional scarring
the best way to defend against a bogot
is ridiculous
aka the boggart banishing charm which
makes the pocket
look well ridiculous apparently the best
way to face a boggart is to bring
someone along with you
as it will struggle when trying to
decide which form to take
two people means two sets of fears and
unless you both fear the same thing
the boggart will have a tough time often
the result of multiple people facing a
boggart
is a combination of their fears which
often comes across
as silly rather than scary it's also
worth mentioning that a boggart's
ability to shapeshift
can sometimes be subject to limitations
i.e
when a pocket transforms into something
it's limited by the size of the room
that it inhabits furthermore because of
voldemort's looming presence in the
wizarding world
it just so happened that he was what
most people feared most
and so for this reason he was most
people's boggart
however the question remains what does a
boggart actually
look like are we sure that no one can
see a boggart's real form
we know that boggarts hide in dark
places and these dark places can include
enclosures
like chests assuming a boggart is inside
a chest
and you were to approach said chest the
pocket would not transform
because you aren't face to face with it
so technically
technically this should mean that if you
are somehow able to look
through the chest you should be able to
see the true form of a boggart
right can anyone do this in comes
madaimudi
aleister maddai moody was a scottish
pure blood wizard born into the moody
family
a family known for producing a plethora
of amazingly talented auras
in his youth he attended hogwarts school
of witchcraft and wizardry
and later on in his life and career true
to his family name
went on to become one of the most famous
and respected auras
of all time auras are of course members
of an elite and highly trained unit of
magical law enforcement
they work for the department of magical
law enforcement in the ministry of magic
and are trained to investigate dark
crimes
and detain dark witches and wizards
becoming an aura is certainly no easy
feat
and given that moody was arguably the
most famous aura to have ever lived
i'm sure he was nothing short of
exceptional moody played a pivotal role
during both the first and second
wizarding wars but during the first
he had the most impact as he dove fully
into protecting the wizarding world
fighting against the forces of darkness
moody ended up losing an
eye a leg and part of his nose in an
effort to piece himself back together
moody found artificial replacements for
his limbs
what this meant was that his eye was
eventually replaced with a new
magical eye while moody certainly
sported a very jarring physical
appearance
overall his most notable physical
characteristic
was his eyes one was small dark
and otherwise normal while the other was
a huge
electric blue magical eye that moved
around
entirely independently from his normal
eye this is how moody got the nickname
madai the new eye that moody received
however functioned as much more than his
original eye
you see moody's magical eye had the
ability to see through things that a
regular eye couldn't
things like invisibility cloaks walls
etc
he could even see through the back of
his own head this brings us back to
boggarts
in the order of the phoenix when they're
at sirius's house moody is asked to
check if there is a boggart in one of
the rooms upstairs
to which he confirms that there is
indeed a boggart
we've been wanting to ask you for ages
could you have a look in the writing
desk in the drawing room
and tell us what's inside it we haven't
wanted to open it just in case
it's something really nasty no problem
molly
moody's electric blue eye swiveled
upward and stared
fixedly through the ceiling of the
kitchen drawing room
he growled as the pupil contracted desk
in the corner
yeah i see it yeah it's a pocket want me
to go up and get rid of it molly
now it's long been professed that no one
knows what the true form of a boggart
looks like but if moody was able to look
through the chest without the bogut
knowing
then presumably moody was able to see
the boggart
in its regular form so did he
this is up for some debate first things
first based on lupin's logic when
explaining the properties of pockets to
students
moody very well should be able to see
its true form
so the pocket sitting in the darkness
within has not yet assumed a form
he does not yet know what will frighten
the person on the other side of the door
nobody knows what a boggart looks like
when he is alone but when i let him out
he will immediately become whatever each
of us most fears
we can assume that the pocket was in its
natural form
because he hadn't yet been presented
with anyone to scare
therefore yes moody saw it however
jk rowling herself has expressed that no
one actually knows what the true form
looks like
so what moody saw is totally up to our
own interpretation
they are strange creatures and i think
that rather than seeing a physical form
giving the boggart a natural appearance
moody simply saw a presence of some kind
maybe even just heat it's hard to say
and that's because boggarts aren't even
alive
they're non-beings they're generated
entirely by human emotions
much like poltergeists which leads me to
believe that though moody identified the
creature as a bogot
it doesn't necessarily mean that he
knows what a pocket looks like
does that make sense i hope so what do
you guys think
could moody see the true natural form of
a pocket
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you